[Musique]
ça fait très américain comme ça et
pourtant c'est à bordeaux que ça se
passe dans les années 80 le drive-in
cinéma rassembler des jeunes et leur
bolide le temps d'une séance
c'est une intimité à l'intérieur d'une
voiture qui est pas du tout la même que
celle qu'on peut vivre dans une salle de
cinéma le tout premier drive in de
france c'était en 1967 à la farlède près
de thoune ou même si l'invention est
américaine ce n'est pas du tout outre
atlantique que le créateur de cet espace
à trouver l'inspiration
mais lors d'un voyage à naïrobi au kenya
j'avais trouvé sa sensationnelle ça
correspondait vraiment à une forme
nouvelle du cinéma classique et quand je
suis rentré en france
un jour je me suis posé la question mais
pourquoi n'y at il pas des drive-in en
france au passage en caisse
un haut-parleur reliées à un fil et
distribués il n'ya plus qu'à se garer
face à un poteau et profiter d'un film
depuis la voiture je vois que décidé de
lancer le cinéma des chiens aussi
d'appeler canada seule possibilité de
l'amener d'ailleurs dans ces conditions
le drive-in c'est le signer en toute
liberté à écouter ses spectateurs à
marseille en 1969 j'étais ablettes en
famille on peut fumer on peut parler on
peut commenter le film sans déranger les
voisins
sur un corner pour les verts c'est comme
beaucoup de vue et je vais pas au rouge
après avoir gagné le sud de la france
le drive in a tenté de conquérir la
région parisienne ça se passe à rungis
en 1970
il ya encore un peu de pédagogie à faire
les franciliens ont vite eu l'occasion
de découvrir le plus grand écran
d'europe à l'époque 600 mètres carrés
le prix 4 francs par voiture + 6 à 8
francs par personne
la recette american a pris pendant
quelques années mais le ciné-parc
d'orangi c'est devenu un gouffre
financier et a dû fermer ses grilles la
france l'europe même avait rêvé de la
jouer à l'américaine la mode n'aura fait
que passer
aujourd'hui il n'existe plus de ciné
parcs en france
en revanche les séances en plein air se
sont développées partout pendant la
saison estivale
hors de la voiture la tête sous les
étoiles
[Musique]